all right in 2020 vice president Mike
Pence absolutely demolished Kamala
Harris during their debate so how did he
do tonight against his fellow
Republicans let's take a look
Martha U.S you asked earlier who's
best prepared for this job and I must
say with all due respect to all of my
friends on the stage and even the one
that's probably looking on
I think unquestionably I am the best
prepared
the most tested the most qualified and
proven conservative in this race I was a
leader in the Congress of the United
States I led Indiana where we balanced
budgets and had a triple a bond rating
when I was governor and as Vice
President of the United States we spent
funding to to backfill on the the
military cuts of the Obama
Administration and then we were there in
the worst pandemic in 100 years
all right here with us now former vice
president Mike Pence uh Mr Vice
President how are you good to see you
again thank you for being here thank you
you know I'm the best prepared most
tested
um then you had a little exchange with
Vivek and it was over this issue it's
you actually said it's not time for
on-the-job training not time for a
rookie right and called him out when he
said that and quoted him saying that a
president can't do everything right uh
well I mean he's flashy he's got a great
smile very personable smart obviously
successful
um not ready that's your take
well that that is uh that's part of my
take but look I I was glad to be on that
stage I thought Brett and Martha did a
terrific job really getting us to a
broad range I do too I think they did a
great job but look
the country is in serious trouble right
now
I mean Joe Biden's disastrous withdrawal
from Afghanistan has has unleashed the
enemies of Freedom around the world and
at the same time he's been cutting
military spending he threw open the
southern border of the United States we
have the worst crisis Border in history
this Avalanche of spending has now
created the worst inflation in 40 years
mortgage rates reached a 21-year high
last week uh and and the steady assault
on our values uh and and our core
Liberties religious freedoms it's it
this is no no time
for on-the-job training I I really the
reason that my wife and I after after
much prayer stepped into this racehawn
as I've told you before
is because when we look at the blessings
we've had in our life
where I was a leader among house
conservatives for 12 years I actually we
moved the deficit reduction act when
George Bush was president it was the
last time we actually had a meaningful
cut uh in government spending on the
books in history I go home to Indiana I
balance budgets I cut taxes we achieve
record employment and then uh you know I
was a leading voice for the conservative
agenda in the Trump Pence Administration
and administration I'm incredibly proud
of I know there was some criticism of
our record I tried to get in on it a
couple of times to defend our record but
look to me this my message is that I say
with great humility
when I look at the challenges facing
America
and I look at the experiences we've had
I'm simply the most
experienced proven tested conservative
in this field and it's that kind of
experience conservative leadership
that's going to be required to turn this
country around if you look on the issue
of borders if you look on the issue of
energy Independence if you look at the
issue of American foreign policy in Law
and Order and on so many of these issues
then you guys got hit with a pandemic
you know the worst the worst one in a
hundred years right and I think that
through everybody for a loop and nobody
in the beginning knew anything let's be
honest and I think everyone was just
flailing around a little bit trying your
best to you know understand the
magnitude of what we're dealing with
here that that certainly up to that
point you had set record low
unemployment for every single
demographic in the country and achieved
energy Independence and beat the
caliphate and solimani and baghdadi and
Associates a lot of success there well
it's it's one of the great deals and
yeah I I tried to get back to a little
bit on covet after Governor DeSantis you
know lines about that yeah
um and he's entitled his opinion but
he's not entitled to his own facts I
mean look when I was tapped two months
into that task force to lead the White
House coronavirus task force by
President trump our number one Focus was
to save lives to make sure health care
workers had the testing and the
resources the supplies and ultimately
the vaccines right that would see our
nation through this we we spun up
support for families and businesses in
paycheck protection and there was an
enormous investment in that but I
believe that's what government is for
you know when the roof Falls in when
when when when when hard times strike a
nation that's why you have to balance
your budget that's why you have to be on
a solid fiscal Foundation one of the
things we never talked about tonight was
we have a national debt the size of our
nation's economy today for the first
time since World War II and and I was
the first one to be willing to step up
and say look as president of the United
States I'm going to say to everybody
over the age of 40 no changes in Social
Security or Medicare but for Americans
under the age of 40. I want to have a
conversation it's headed towards
insolvency
Joe Biden's policy is insolvency and
candidly my former running mate's policy
is identical to Joe Biden's but but even
you know I had to call out vivec on that
he literally said uh that he wasn't
going to do anything about the national
debt Social Security and Medicare reform
because he said the president can't do
everything the president can't do
everything and I just said to him you
know I was in the building I was in the
hallway I was in the Oval Office for
four years almost every day presidents
don't get to choose you have to look
those crises in the eye you have to
provide leadership and solve them and I
will
vice president Pence great to see you
thank you Sean hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else